[Music]
on this thursday night
judgment day is on the way for the two
michaels
trials in china with no witnesses no
transparency
what you're going to see is a deliberate
act of humiliation
what are ottawa's options to secure
their freedom
allegations that sexual misconduct is
running rampant through canada's
military
i encourage you to tell your truth
what's stopping more victims from
stepping forward
big boost the vaccines coming from our
neighbors
i'll drive down there my pickup and pick
them up if we have to could this signal
a reopening of the border
and reinflating the atlantic bubble
optimism rises over this part of canada
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight
robin gill good evening and thank you
for joining us tonight canadians michael
spavor and michael kovrick are preparing
to stand
trial they have spent 829 days in jail
in china
accused of spying the two men were
detained separately in december 2018.
their arrests are widely seen as
retaliation for the arrest of huawei
executive
mangwon zhou in british columbia mung
was arrested at the request of the
united states
accused of violating american sanctions
but the two situations
couldn't be more different she's out on
bail living in a multi-million dollar
home in vancouver
while the two canadians have had limited
contact with their families
and the outside world for more than two
years spavor will be in a chinese court
in a matter of hours
kovrik's hearing is scheduled for monday
as abigail beeman explains
the timing of the long-awaited trials is
likely not a coincidence
they didn't allow any defense evidence
to be presented
so we were completely crippled in that
trial peter humphrey is one of the few
westerners to know what michael spavor
and michael calvert
are facing he was convicted in a chinese
court in 2014
and maintained his innocence now he
helps others in the same situation
you're not going to see a real trial
here what you're going to see
is a deliberate act of humiliation and
these two men have
actually no no real means of defending
themselves
he expects a conviction more than 99 of
chinese court cases end that way
normally a small number of of people in
the
in the courtroom family members etc
that this is not the case would be due
to the fact that this is a
national security issue former diplomat
gordon holden has been in the courtroom
when other canadians were on trial in
china
he was hoping coffer against spavor
would have a consular presence
global affairs says despite several
requests canadian officials have not
received permission to attend the trials
and remain deeply troubled by a lack of
transparency
to be absolutely shut out to the court
process
is simply wrong i do not believe that
it's in in accordance with the
vienna convention on constant relations
or of the canada china
concert agreement we should be prepared
for the worst
but we shouldn't be so pessimistic to
draw the conclusion
in advance that they will receive guilty
conviction
lynette ong is not jumping to
conclusions because the case is so
unusual and so political she says the
timing is odd with china and the u.s
meeting in alaska
thursday some believe the chinese may be
trying to use the case as a bargaining
chip
the americans are in a pretty tight spot
what are they going to do are they going
to give into
what we call hostage negotiations
but or on the other hand are they going
to do it
because these are two lives at stake
michael spaver's family has largely
stayed quiet at his request but released
a statement saying they now feel it
necessary to call for his unconditional
release
citing a belief in his innocence and a
lack of transparency in his case
while michael covering's wife tells
global news learning about the looming
trial is overwhelming to process
but she is continuing to focus on trying
to bring him home
abigail beeman global news ottawa this
all puts the spotlight on our federal
government and exactly what it is doing
to help the two canadians
let's bring in our chief political
correspondent david aiken and david i
think a lot of canadians are wondering
why doesn't canada just trade mung for
the two michaels well in fact a lot of
former senior liberals are john manley
john mccallum for example a lot of
former diplomats they have also
advocated just that a trade but
prime minister justin trudeau has
rejected the idea every time
trudeau's point is the minute canada
agrees to such a deal
is the minute a target goes on the back
of every canadian abroad
every dodgy regime in the world would
know if you want something from canada
simply throw a local canadian in jail
and second
even if trudeau wanted to make that
trade there would be
howls in this country that he'd be
interfering in the independent canadian
judicial process
now dealing with mong's case and of
course aside from showing that canada
was
a nation of laws only if convenient it
would also be politically dangerous for
trudeau because remember
the liberals took a big hit in the polls
for alleged interfering in the
snc lavaland case robin so david what
has the government done
so far and what more can it do the
government
has actually done quite a bit though
most of it is behind the scenes
diplomatic activity
the two michaels have been a constant
topic in just about every meeting or
phone call
foreign ministers freeland champaign and
now garneau have had with any
international counterpart and that work
culminated this spring in the first ever
global treaty banning arbitrary
detention the entire g7 including the
u.s signed on to that
and i'll tell you what it very much got
china's attention the goal for canada
here
is to get its allies like the u.s
constantly telling china
that china's hostage diplomacy is
counterproductive
that china's standing in the world will
be diminished
and that china is holding back its own
economic success
robin david aiken in ottawa thanks david
turning now to allegations of sexual
misconduct in the military
one of the most senior women in the
canadian forces spoke to global news
about
her personal experiences and why she's
walking away
in part two of our exclusive interview
lieutenant colonel eleanor taylor talks
about the harm associated with reporting
the abuse
and why it's so important to end the
silence here's our auto bureau chief
mercedes stevenson
lieutenant colonel eleanor taylor is a
warrior she willingly signed up to take
on threats to canada
but the silent insidious enemy within
she didn't expect
now she is speaking out about what she
believes happens to most women in the
canadian forces
and why women are afraid to break rank
and report
the consequences of being alienated by
the group
are greater than the consequences in
some cases
of whatever inappropriate sexual
behavior we are dealing with
and so we choose to manage the
inappropriate behavior
and never report for the first time
taylor is revealing her own experiences
to highlight the problems in the system
and encourage other women to speak i've
told my story
many times but i have never
shared the fact that i i too
have struggled with this behavior
because in so doing
i feel that i risk the reputation of the
team
and risk alienating myself from the team
the
the potential pain of being ostracized
in that way
is almost seen to be worse than the pain
of dealing with the sexual misconduct or
the sexual violence
i had instances where i
experienced either
highly sexual highly inappropriate
sexual behavior
um you know an example started during my
training when my very earliest training
where we had an instructor who was who
had a relationship with one of the 17
year old students
where we had an instructor who would get
drunk
and make inappropriate advances i have
had
an experience where somebody that was a
significantly higher rank than me
earlier in my career
insisted that i go to his room with him
and when i arrived there
he sat on the bed and turned on
pornography and in my case
in that case i chose not to report
because i knew that by reporting i would
bring myself
far greater harm
that was not worth the cost taylor says
the culture in the military has to
change
otherwise women like her will continue
to leave i think it has a significant
impact on the longevity of
women and victims who are not women in
uniform
and because you can take this behavior
and deal with it for a few years without
recognizing the cost that it has on your
the cost that it has on you personally
lieutenant colonel taylor is encouraging
other women to speak she believes that
now is the chance for change in the
institution that she loves
so much she was willing to give her life
and her career for
mercedes stephenson global news ottawa
canada is getting a big vaccine boost
from the u.s
the white house says it will lend canada
1.5 million doses of the oxford
astrazeneca vaccine
in january ontario premier doug ford
appealed directly to u.s president joe
biden
to send vaccines to canada today he's
grateful our neighbors
are willing to help oh god bless america
they're coming to our rescue
thank god i've been bugging trump i've
been jumping bugging biden all of them
they must get sick of doug ford
asking for help the biden administration
is under pressure from allies worldwide
to share vaccines
particularly from astrozenica our
washington bureau chief jackson proskow
is following these developments so
why is the u.s willing to share now well
robin there's a couple reasons even
though as you mentioned the vaccine is
widely approved around the world
it is not yet approved for use here in
the u.s in fact there are
seven million doses just sitting in a
warehouse unused right now and so until
the fda greenlights the astrazeneca
vaccine here
the u.s has decided to share and at the
same time the u.s has enough doses of
other vaccines that it doesn't really
need this one there will be vaccine for
every american by the end of may
but perhaps the bigger impetus in all of
this is the border closure it has been
nearly a year since non-essential
travel between canada the us and mexico
was cut off
the white house believes that bringing
the pandemic under control everywhere
is key to getting the borders open again
now the final terms of this agreement
are still being hashed out but the white
house has described it as effectively
a loan that will eventually have to be
repaid in vaccine doses
somewhere down the line it's worth
noting though that both canada and the
us have purchased way more vaccine than
they actually need
the issue right now really is more just
about availability enough supply
and so this vaccine loan is essentially
about making doses available for
sooner for canadians robin jackson
frosco in washington thanks jackson
and there's more optimism with canada's
vaccine rollout
procurement numbers show there are more
than enough doses coming to have every
canadian receive their first shot
by the end of june hopefully we will be
in a spot
you know in a few months and where every
canadian
will have received you know if if that's
what each jurisdiction is
is moving forward with that one dose and
then
obviously also being able to offer that
second dose
today europe's health regulator declared
the astrazeneca vaccine
safe and effective there were concerns
when a small percentage of people
suffered blood clots after they received
the shot
that prompted more than a dozen
countries to suspend the use of the
vaccine
as crystal commansing reports the
vaccination campaign
is back on track use the vaccine
it's effective and safe that's the
message from the european medicines
agency
its benefits in protecting people from
covet 19 with the associated risks of
death and hospitalization
outweigh the possible risks
france which is seeing a record high
number of covid19 patients in its icus
was one of more than a dozen european
member states
to suspend the use of the astrazeneca
vaccine
there were safety concerns following
reports of blood clots
the number of thromboembolic events
reported after vaccination
is lower than the expected in the
general population
and proc has concluded that there is no
increase
in the overall risk of blood clots with
this vaccine
the eu's drug watchdog says it will dig
further to understand the reports of
some rare conditions
following vaccination specifically seven
cases where there was clotting in
multiple blood vessels
and 18 cases of clots combined with
bleeding in the brain
if it was me i would i would be
vaccinated tomorrow
but i would want to know that if
anything happened to me after
vaccination what i should do about it
the european medicines agency is
recommending an
update to the drug information leaflet
and it's highlighting some potential
signs to watch out for such as
breathlessness
pain in the chest or stomach swelling or
coldness
in an arm or leg belgium didn't pause
its rollout and those being jabbed had
no hesitation
i spoke to my daughter and he said it's
a very good
vaccine i have a great confidant in the
exit
why not astrazeneca is a good
vaccine it's expected many of the
countries that halted its use
will put it back into rotation crystal
commansing global news
london the new alarm in saskatchewan's
capital city
coming up the race to vaccinate regina
as dangerous variants spread
the number of people testing positive
for those highly contagious variants
is climbing in canada according to the
federal public health agency
more than 4 200 variant cases have now
been confirmed
a vast majority more than 3 900 are the
b117 variant
first identified in the uk ontario is
bearing the brunt of these mutated forms
of the virus it has the most cases of
the variance compared to other provinces
but those variants are taking hold in
much of western canada
nearly all of saskatchewan's new coven
19 cases
are from the b-117 variant and they're
concentrated
in regina as roberta bell reports there
are calls for more restrictions
certainly the fact that where the hot
spot in the country does make me
concerned
a year ago today everyone was thinking
it was going to be over in two weeks
in the early days of the pandemic there
were proportionately very few
coveted cases in saskatchewan's capital
for a period of weeks last spring
there were actually none at all but now
public health officials say they're
watching regina closely
two weeks three weeks ago we couldn't
predict where
the veins of concern would take over
right now they've taken over in china
there are 527 active coveted cases in
regina
489 of them 93 percent are confirmed or
presumptive variants of concern
this epidemiologist warns it won't stay
local for long
we are seeing a surge in regina
but it will soon be seen in other
communities in saskatchewan as well
in fact as of thursday saskatchewan
reported a total 568 confirmed or
presumptive variant of concern cases
making up 44 percent of the province's
1282
active cases the nature of this pandemic
is now pivoting to a more threatening
more dangerous face regina mayor sandra
masters says she's watching the
situation closely
my offer was we're prepared to do
anything that the chief medical officer
is is thinking will be necessary
restrictions in saskatchewan
relaxed last week to allow expanded
household bubbles of up to 10 people
regardless of what you're allowed to do
just because you can doesn't mean you
should
while regina residents aren't facing any
new public health orders
provincial officials say vaccines are
being diverted to them in a race against
the rapidly spreading variants
roberta bell global news regina
still ahead new rules for medically
assisted death
why advocates for the most vulnerable
are worried
there's new hope tonight for canadians
suffering with intolerable pain
a bill expanding access to assisted
death has received royal assent
those who aren't near their natural
death now have the right to seek medical
assistance in dying
but as heather york's west reports some
groups feel the new law puts
some vulnerable canadians at risk janet
hopkins has been living with a serious
autoimmune disease for the last 13
years she says she lives in constant
pain
since last february i have been
thinking of suicide i've talked to my
family about it
because the pain is excruciating when
you get a flare-up
because her condition was not
life-threatening hopkins had not been
eligible for a medically assisted death
but with the passing of bill c-7 on
wednesday
that all changed i started to cry
because i've wanted this for so long
under the new law intolerably suffering
canadians who aren't near death become
immediately eligible it also removes a
requirement that patients be able to
give
final consent at the time of their death
and that's wonderful because what's
happened in the past is many people have
had to opt to take their death early in
order to avoid that situation because
they
were at such fear and risk of losing
capacity the government had until next
week to bring the law into compliance
with the 2019 quebec superior court
ruling
that found canada's previous law was
unconstitutional
in two years access will also expand to
those suffering with severe
mental illness something opponents worry
will put vulnerable canadians
at risk particularly those from
indigenous communities
where mental health supports can be
difficult to access
it sends a culturally and socially
acceptable message that suicide
is one option to
end one's suffering and that is contrary
to our message
that we're sending to our youth the new
law requires people not facing imminent
death
undergo a 90-day assessment before a
medically assisted death
can be accessed heather urex west global
news calgary
up next atlantic bubble 2.0 and why
there's a burst
of hope
the exclusive atlantic travel bubble is
making a comeback
round two is expected to begin in april
once again allowing locals only to move
freely
while restricting outsiders from
visiting a spike in kovan 19 cases in
november bursts the bubble but as ross
lord reports
with vaccinations on the rise there's
renewed hope
in this part of canada for atlanta
canada re-establishing the atlantic
bubble is a show of confidence i think
that everyone has been wanting to see
opportunities to travel throughout our
region the bubble imploded in november
after a spike in covert 19 cases forcing
people to self-isolate
if they traveled outside of their own
province two weeks there and then to
come back and isolate for another two
weeks and
i it's just too hard it's it's difficult
to take that amount of time
off to make a trip to new brunswick
it's been tough on kathleen armstrong
and tough on her mother
grace no matter if they're 5 years old
or 30 years old
they need their mom and dad they they
like to share their news
especially this news my fiance brad and
i got engaged the first weekend in
december they're itching to celebrate
the ring in person
it's an exciting time i i'm waiting to
actually see it and feel it and touch it
and
and all that travel restrictions will
ease on april 19th
talks are also underway about allowing
visitors to enter from outside the
atlantic region
i'm pretty confident that you know when
we put this behind us i think all of
atlanta canada
is going to jump up a notch or two in
everybody's list excitement
is already building it was instantly a
phone call to mom like
they're saying this date and we've got
to get on the road and i'm calling
boutiques and you need to look at hotels
and
tell my sister to take time off of work
so she can come too
new hope that a return to normal is
getting closer
ross lord global news
and that is global national for this
thursday night i'm robin gill
we'll stay in the atlantic for tonight's
your canada which is chelten beach in
prince edward island
we would love to see your corner of the
country so please keep sending your
photos to viewers at globalnational.com
thank you for watching and i'll see you
back here tomorrow have a great night
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you